we learned overnight that Prince Harry
this is my favorite story today Prince
Harry and Megan Markell they're
expecting their very first child the
royal family broke the news on Twitter
shortly after the Duke and Duchess
Duchess of susat Sussex arrived in
Australia
the royal couple they're in Sydney
Australia starting their first official
royal tour since getting married back in
May
Jonathan Vigliotti is in Sydney with
them Jonathan good morning and good
morning and talk about a way to kick off
your first overseas tour as a royal
couple we're here outside the iconic
Sydney Opera House joined by the
international media earlier this
afternoon we were called in for a
meeting what we were promised would be a
surprise announcement and you have to
imagine the moment a roomful of normally
chatty journalists fell silent
fresh off there over 20 hour flight from
London senior arriving at Sydney's
International Airport Prince Harry and
Duchess Megan made their bombshell
announcement the couple's first child is
due some time in the spring royal expert
Roy Anika calls it an historic moment
Megan is an American she's the first
mixed-race woman to marry into the royal
family we're gonna have the first
mixed-race child in the royal family
but I think the Queen rooms the what
Hani will be absolutely thrilled
Kensington Palace says the couple first
told the Queen and their extended royal
family at Princess Eugenie's wedding on
Friday before getting married last May
Prince Harry and Megan were open about
their desires to start a family
speaking on British television children
near being the key word
the Queen is said to be thrilled by the
news the couple are here for their first
international royal visit to Australia
Fiji Tonga and New Zealand which is now
raising health concerns because of Zika
warnings in Fiji and Tonga Harry and
Megan have taken medical advice from
doctors back in the UK about the rest
easy care in Fiji and Tonga and they've
decided on that medical advice that they
will carry on and nothing will change
and you also have to worry about this
other big concern which is just sheer
exhaustion think about this over the
next two and a half weeks this couple
will travel to four countries
seventy-six engagements
we're told right now they're getting
their rest at the governor's house
before their first official appearance
tomorrow morning here outside the Opera
House will their would make their first
appearance before a very excited public
and Norah for those who are keeping
count this baby will be seventh in line
to the throne
Wow Jonathan Vigliotti insignia Sydney
Australia
thank you it's a lot of engagement it's
not a babymoon but we know that women
who are pregnant they run marathons
they've been the Australian Open last
Serena's yeah and be done hopefully she
won't have the morning sickness that
Kate had right yeah we can actually do
stuff while you're pregnant she's 37
he's 34 I think it's great great great
that's to them